- I wasn't like no scholar in high school
and stuff like that—didn't go to college.
So this has got to be
off straight gut instinct
and what I know.
What's up, folks? Ron Killings.
Also known as R-Truth WWE.
And this is my bracket.
All right.
We're gonna get into this bracket right now. OK.
Them and I got history. I know all of
these guys on here.
These iconic legends on here.
Just to keep it real with y'all.
Austin.
Bob Backlund.
Got to go with Austin on that one.
Aight. Bob still got that chickenwing for
you, though.
Brock Lesnar and Taker.
Bam! Brock.
Hogan and Rey.
Rey Mysterio
es mi amigo.
Que lastima! Ha ha ha, yeah!
John Cena and Booker.
Damn, Book my dawg.
I like John, too, you know what I'm
saying? That's my childhood hero.
But Book's my dawg.
Shawn Michaels and Kurt.
OK, damn.
I just saw Kurt yesterday.
Ric Flair and Eddie.
Damn, y'all.
Uhh. Bam! Damn, Eddie got it, y'all. Sorry
about that.
OK.
Bret Hart and Jericho.
I just saw Natalya, which is
Bret's niece.
So I might have to pick that.
I saw her last week.
Rock and Bruno Sammartino.
OK, shoot, man.
I like Rock.
Boom!
So this is my bracket.
Now we're getting down to who's going to
win between these guys.
Ah, man.
Ahh, I like Austin.
"3:16, then you got your ass whooped."
But Brock is a mountain of a man.
Rey and Booker.
Book, you my dawg,
boy, I love you, Book! Damn, I love Book.
Ah!
Damn, I didn't push Book?
Well, Rey Mysterio.
Kurt Angle and Eddie.
Dawg.
I saw Kurt a week
ago, but we just talked
about Eddie,
and I got a new T-shirt from him.
So Eddie gonna get that one.
Bret and Rock.
Ah, man. Oh, y'all did me like that.
Bret and Rock. Hmm.
That's my bracket.
Aight, this is my final four.
Brock Lesnar, Rey Mysterio,
Eddie Guerrero and
The Rock.
I wasn't like no scholar
in high school and stuff like that—didn't
go to college.
So this has got to be
off straight gut instinct
and what I know.
Rey Mysterio versus
The Rock.
That's my two to go at it, you know?
Give it to me.
Rey Mysterio and The Rock.
Boom!
Decisions, decisions. Ah, man.
I just saw Rey.
I haven't seen Rock in a while.
It's really going to who I've seen
recently, you know what I'm saying?
That's what—we should stick to that, you
know what I'm saying?
Out of sight, out of mind, right?
But I know, Rock. I know 'em.
I just, um, ain't got his phone number!
All right, guys.
You got it.
Rey Mysterio.
This is my pick.
This is my bracket.
If you got one better, let's see
it. Let's see.
Show me your bracket. Show me your picks.
Show me your lineup.
Who you got?
This is mine. And again,
"Set It Off" is available on all digital
platforms.
Go check it out on YouTube, and you
can set it off yourself.